riesgo sanitario en Chile decenas de
lobos marinos están apareciendo muertos
en las costas chilenas la causa la gripe
aviar por ello el municipio de arica
tuvo que cerrar las cuevas de anzota uno
de sus grandes atractivos turísticos
sabemos que esto va a golpear la
economía de un sector importante de
nuestra ciudad sin embargo tenemos un
alto número de cuerpos de lobos marinos
que han muerto producto de la gripe
aviar esto después de que el miércoles
se diese a conocer el primer caso de
gripe había reportado en un humano en
Chile las entidades de salud chilenas
empezaron a vacunar a trabajadores de
granjas estamos acá evitando la
influencia de llamamos hacemos ese
llamado categórico tenemos ya el primer
caso en humano que es un caso extraño
Por lo tanto tenemos que seguir actuando
como lo hemos hecho hasta ahora el
primer contagio en humanos del último
brote se detectó en una niña en Ecuador
en enero las autoridades señalan que es
posible que el virus se transmita de
aves y mamíferos marinos a humanos pero
es rara la transmisión entre personas
granjas aviares en chile y Argentina
detectaron casos en los últimos meses
por lo que han tenido que detener sus
exportaciones el virus fue descubierto
en 2014 en Norteamérica la organización
Panamericana de la salud alertado de un
fuerte rebrote durante el 2023 siendo
detectado en 10 países de la región